once you've finished the short
screenplay what are the first steps in
making the movie so here's the thing I'm
actually a believer of don't do the
screenplay first I think you need to
think about what you want to tell and
then can you tell it because if you're
actually making this thing and financing
it yourself it's not like a feature
where you're writing the whole script
and then you're going around to people
and trying to get funding for short film
more realistically it's either going to
be like you're shooting it in class
because you have to or you're funding it
yourself to get it made so I I don't
think it's worthwhile writing a script
that you can't actually get made for
example a filmmaker that I produced his
first short film for the second short
film he had this great idea that had a
big water effects happening it's like
who's who can afford that who knows
anyone who can do the water effect and
just the film has never been made
because just couldn't do it that way so
you can write it but you know if if
you're not thinking like I'm actually
making this then you could write
something that you just never afford to
do you could do it as an exercise but so
I think it's more important to think
about okay what do you actually want to
make and how can you make it what do you
have access to that it could work well
for a short film and that's why a lot of
short films and low budget features like
shot in homes because everyone was like
well I have my own home I could shoot my
own home and that's true you totally can
but you also have like your car and you
also have you know you could go shooting
your office building or you could go
shoot at the park or you could go shoot
you know your friend has a pool why not
set something in the pool so I think
it's important to kind of think first
about I call it organic filmmaking what
do you actually have access to when I
teach low budget filmmaking I can't tell
you often people have hospitals in their
script it's like how you gonna get a
hospital you know hospitals don't be
like sure just show up and we'll let you
shoot here so if you wrote an entire
short film that was set in the hospital
only do that if you have access to
either you can pay for a hospital set or
you have access to a hospital in some
way I think it's more important to think
about well what do I actually have
access What story do I want to tell what
do I actually have access to and can I
write something for that so then it's
less money because you already have
access to all of that and it's more
unique you know it's like think about it
that way I many short films do we see
that are based in pools not that many
but if you have an access to a pool you
can come up with something really unique
that is set in that pool that would make
a really interesting short film so think
about that first before you write it but
like you know you should if you're a
horror filmmaker don't do the I will do
a sunny story about somebody in a pool
in a diving contest or something like
that no you should do a Horror Story set
in a pool but won't that be unique
because how many horror stories are set
in a pool so think about what you
actually have access to if you're you
have to say to yourself I'm actually
going to make this thing so I'm actually
going to make it I'm going to probably
have to fund it myself
how what how can I do it as cheap as
possible and still have it look great
and the answer is use things that you
can actually get for free so your uncle
owns a dry cleaner fabulous how many dry
cleaner shorts do we know very few let's
figure out something that you can tell
the story that means something to you in
a dry cleaners thing and it'll be horror
filming or dry cleaners I would love to
see that I think it would be really
special and unique so don't just write
it to write it write it in the sense of
I'm going to make this so can I actually
make it and if you can't make it then
you have to kind of put it aside in the
drawer until you're at the point that
you know the right people that can do
all these special effects that you hope
to do I also think that's also why you
want to think about what your background
is too like you know if you are for
example a a stunt man and you want to
move into being a director stunt person
and you want to move into being a
director well you have a lot of access
in The Stunt World and people are going
to expect you to do something kind of
stunty so use all of that and that's the
kind of short film that you should make
and write
now that comes the story part and that's
not so easy but at least you have that
Arena of like I'm a stunt person people
are gonna expect some people think I
want to direct things that are stunt
heavy I know four different 10 people I
know would be great in this I know this
location that they'll let me use for
free okay now what kind of story can I
create in this
and sometimes you're not the right
writer for it maybe you're like I'm a
stunt man I'm not a writer ah but I've
met you know or maybe you'd have to take
a class take a class with writing so you
can meet writers or you know find
somebody who will write it for you you
don't have to absolutely do everything
yourself
you can do everything yourself and
sometimes it's cheaper if you do
everything yourself but um you know work
to your strengths and figure out what
you can do but go in the ethereum I'm
going to make it because there's no
point having like a whole drawer of
short film scripts nobody's gonna there
are a few contests for short film
scripts
um so if you want to do that I say again
more power to you and those maybe you're
writing more for people to read them and
to give you Awards and know that they're
not necessarily going to give the award
to the horror story set in the
laundromat or the dry cleaner but um
don't write it just to write it write it
because you're going to actually make it
sure so it sounds like sit down decide
what do I have access to what's actually
in my wheelhouse what can I do and then
once you know okay I have this dry
cleaner for you know it's my uncle's dry
cleaner uh store whatever I know that
he'll let me on the day that they you
know check out the clothes on Sunday
right right on Mondays three Mondays if
I need to right right they know that's
their slow day so they'll and then you
know we have this like say a serial
killer that leaves a letter and a jacket
or something and and there you go and
then and so then the the young dry clean
worker tries to figure out who it
belongs to anyway but but no another
field we're gonna go there we go that's
the great thing there's so many ideas is
out there right and then you just have
to say is this what I really want to put
my time and effort into making sure and
then that's when you start the script
okay that's what you just read the
script and then when you write the
script it doesn't mean like it's come
out of my computer I'm ready to shoot
then you really have to look at is this
a strong beginning is this a strong
ending is every scene start and end at
the right time you really want to be
very critical on the script stage
because you're going to actually make
this it's not just to be read by people
and say you're a very talented writer
we're not going to hire you but we see
that there's Talent here and we're going
to you know get you an agent or
something like that is nobody wants to
read a short script you know it is
literally a document to be made
so you know
be tight and do all your criticism of
what works and what doesn't work before
you go shoot it because it's nothing
worse than you know coming away with a
long you thought it was going to be I
always tell people like if your script
is 12 pages long it's not going to be a
12 minute short it's going to be a 15
minute short you know that rule of one
page one minute doesn't it's not
concrete of always going to turn out
that way so if you're and quite often
short films are more leisurely paced
than they should be
so if you write an eight page script
that's more likely going to end up being
a 10 to 12 page film it just expands
beyond what was actually on the page oh
that's great I didn't actually think
about that so so then
yeah less is more yes you're gonna have
credits at the end et cetera et cetera
so don't you know I'm gonna make a
12-minute film it's a 12-page script
here we go no no okay so also you don't
want to spend all that money for it like
why shoot the 12 scenes you know in part
driving up to the dry cleaner putting
money in the meter I was like that was a
day that we spend outside doing all that
and turns out we don't need any of that
the story starts inside when the person
walks in the door
right so if let's say it's the it's the
replacement and he's coming in to
somebody's day off and just have him
already in the dry cleaner exactly don't
don't show him uh begrudging and having
to drink coffee and psych himself up to
go there just have him there he sees an
old jacket he feels around oh there's a
letter in there okay great now we've got
a story exactly perfect what if you
don't have a budget what if you can't
pay anyone
so
here's the thing you know for a short
film I always say nobody's making any
money off of this it's totally a labor
of love and everyone who's going to work
on it wants you to succeed wants the
film to succeed wants it to be as great
as it is and people love to help out so
I often say for short film don't pay
anybody you know if you're only asking
for one day or two days on the weekend
people want to help you out they're not
expecting cash however in a proper
production you should be paying people
at least minimum wage you are employing
these people I always say people always
get hurt on a short film it's really
crew-wise you know um you know and if
you're doing sag you have to have
insurance for the actors too there's a
lot of and if you're trying to do this
to learn how to do film making in a
proper way then you should do it the
proper way pay everybody do the eight
hour day or ten hour day 12 hour day do
overtime Etc et cetera do all the
paperwork the way you would do paperwork
for Productions and you're learning how
to do it but I also am a big fan of you
know you and your four friends are gonna
go do this on the sly and you know
you're not paying anybody anything but
you should feed them well that's always
the rules like you know so you can't do
it for like no money but you know get
your mom to cater it or something like
that
um and if it's your friends that are
working with you they're not they want
to help you they want to do a good job
and if you're students and everyone's
kind of under the student umbrella that
way too so you know but you have to be
true to what your film is if you have no
money
then don't write the hospital story that
you don't have access to a hospital
unless you can rent a hospital set
that's truly when you have to set it
that if you have truly no money be
creative think of other ways that you
can do it think of what you um can shoot
and you know often for short film too
like you can steal a lot of shots too
these are not going to be commercially
exhibited more often than not so you
know steal things not like literally
steal things in your pocket but it's two
shots that you don't have permission to
do shots with they can give a lot of
production value and make it unique and
special and you know for a short film
too there's no uh saying that you can't
shoot it for you know one hour here one
hour there two hours here there's no
rule that has to be shot in a
traditional filmmaking way of we're
bringing all these people together for a
limited period of time so um you know
again shoot on your iPhone that you
already own it you already
um you can edit on your iPhone you can
do everything in that way too so shoot
I'd rather you do something great
with what you can afford to do then try
to do something great with not enough
money and it falls flat because you
always say well I can redo it when I
have money it's like no it's been made
that's what it is you're never going to
go back and be like oh now I have
thousands of dollars and I can redo it
but I will also say for a lot of my
students they think like oh I only have
two thousand dollars I'm going to make a
short film it's like yes you totally
can't again I know people who've made
short films for five hundred dollars for
a hundred dollars you can totally do it
for no money but money does start
creeping in and you know I'd rather you
have four thousand dollars to do a
really great short film than two
thousand dollars to do a half-assed
short film